[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai eu un échange
franc direct rapide avec le président
poutine les russes ce matin sont entrés
dans karkhiv presque en silence au
rythme saccadé de la respiration anonyme
de celui qui filme derrière ses
persiennes ça n'a pas produit d'effet
vous le voyez bien pour le moment je
leur donne aux ministres de la défense
et au chef de l'état majeur
de 1 mètre les forces de dissuasion de
l'armée russe à un état spéciale ce qui
est inadmissible c'est que nous
assistions pratiquement un puissant
atermoiements de l'europe
malheureusement sur la longue durée
c'est un dictateur qui ne s'est plus
arrêté qui a mis en place un
gouvernement fantoche en biélorussie
dans le centre ville de kiev en revanche
la nuit a été relativement calme
beaucoup ont passé le couvre-feu en sous
sol dans des parkings le métro avec
leurs chiens ou des compagnons plus
improbables
la nuit passée fut dur de nouveau des
tirs de nouveau des bombardements de
quartier habité
d'infrastructure civile devient
aujourd'hui rien que l'occupant ne
contient pas comme une cible légitime 3
168 milles l'ukrainien son train de
quitter le pays un pays contre 44
millions d'habitants ça c'est une
question qui va se poser à nous est ce
que la france est prête à accueillir des
réfugiés ukrainien oui c'est une
question qui va se poser à l'europe
toute entière j'ai reçu déjà
des propositions de famille qui disent
nous on est prêt à accueillir des
ukrainiens et jean louis bourlanges
député modem qui a été député européen
aussi estime qu'il faut les accueillir
les ukrainiens parce que ce serait une
immigration de qualité dont on pourra
tirer profit ça vous choque oui j'aime
pas le côté utilitariste des baies
réfugiés mais la procédure était ouverte
et donc on fait rentrer l'ukraine des
blancs oui mais je vous soyez bien
erreur vous voyez bien que vous êtes en
train d'apporter de l'eau à ce moulin
l'âge essayant de combler mais non non
vous essayez pas de comprendre vous
essayez de avancé des arguments qui
justifient les positions que je condamne
je suis en colère contre l'ukraine parce
qu'on leur a bien reculé et non il
recommence
pourquoi on doit subir ça l'ukraine
continue de taper à la porte de l'otan
est aussi l'union européenne on lui dit
non définitivement
vous voyez bien que que que vous essayez
de poser dans une période de crise des
questions qui doivent se poser dans des
questions câbles mais qui pourrait
peut-être régler la crise non on n'irait
qui pourraient non je ne le crois pas ça
pourrait rendre la crise plus aiguë chez
nous c'est permanent et ça continue ça
fait huit ans qu'on nous bombarde par
les nôtres par les ukrainiens
combien de temps ça peut encore durer
elle est vue comme larmes économique la
plus puissante exclure l'accès à swift
la plateforme d échanges entre banques
certains grands établissements russes
vont être touchés les établissements
visés n'auront plus accès à ce service
qui facilite le transit d'ordres de
paiement entre banques de transfert de
fonds de leur clientèle ou d'achat et de
vente de valeurs mobilières
c'est vrai à effacer les aventures du
chien douglas qui a voté aux primaires
et l'air vous êtes sûrement kontseilua
le chai à douglas une sanction
complémentaire a été ajouté nous allons
paralyser
les actifs de la banque centrale russe
cela gèlera ces transactions financières
il s'appelle clovis il s'appelle pas du
tout douglas libération dans son enquête
sur l'investiture de valérie pécresse a
préféré changer je vous jure c'est vrai
à changer le nom du chien pourront pas
qu'il est ennuyeux